this is elvira the gal who put the boob
back in the boob tube what's your
relationship with
the book what you've written
how are you feeling oh i alternate
between
thrilled out of my mind and kind of
freaked out going oh my god did i really
say that but then other moments i go
what the hell hey i'm 70. i did it what
am i gonna do cover it up forever you
know everybody wanted me to get a
ghostwriter and i just did not want to
do that i really wanted to tell it in my
own words even though it may not be as
well written as it would have been with
a ghostwriter i just wanted my own voice
and personality to come through with her
personality and wit cassandra writes not
only about her time as elvira but also
about her 19-year relationship with a
woman named teresa and the revelation
was a welcome surprise to the lgbtq plus
community who have long embraced her as
a gay icon they have been fantastic they
have been wonderful i mean
i worried about them because i've always
had a big lgbtq fan base and i worried
that they would think i was a hypocrite
and had been lying to them i never lied
about it i lied by omission you know i
didn't tell anybody but i have always
tried very hard to keep my private life
private because elvira is elvira she's a
character what i do
in my personal life should not affect my
character what was the discussion like
between the two of you when you decided
you were going to
put that in the book it was good and bad
she's she's happy about it she's a
little freaked out she's a very private
person
and
they're kind of shy she doesn't really
like being all over the media
but we were both ready to just stop
living this secret it feels really good
for her i think now at this point
she's a little freaked out about it but
she's uh
liking the fact that we can
be together in public and not
hide it you know